i've noticed there's a pattern of the
same words that every guide says to me
what is it the ball's in your court oh
keep it in your freaking court i don't
want to be playing tennis i don't even
know how that asks for it what ball what
ball yeah how many balls are in this
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey [ __ ] this is
unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine salome do we just become best
friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the on wax podcast
with your favorite favorite sisters
sophia
and sistine stallone
well you guys i've actually had a really
great morning i don't know why i'm
feeling good
by the way high five to that honestly
this last episode i was like you know
what we're waking up happier this is
good i tried i tried but you know what
it was i think coming off of a really
fun weekend
yes makes up for this week i mean yes
there is some residue of me feeling
like i'm sad it's over you know and you
have a really great weekend it's just
kind of like ah i want it to happen
again sunday was a brutal brutal brutal
hangover brutal for us oh my god and we
were the smarties that thought we should
go walk to grab food when it's 110
degrees out in november we also kept
drinking on sunday
me assisting me pulling out a white claw
at 11 o'clock in the morning no you
pulling out a raspberry white claw like
some heathen
the worst flavor ever water what is
wrong with it at first i thought oh this
is kind of great and then after a while
i'm like
no i knew sofia was drunk on saturday
when she's holding a corona
does she look like someone that would
drink beer to you
no
no you know i've reached a level of
intoxication is when i grabbed a beer
willingly no one told me that's true
sophia and i though we have this thing
where we know the night is projected to
be successful
when
this sounds so stupid but maybe people
out there can relate when you
look at your outfit the hair the makeup
and you just snapped look let me explain
this so cysteine i have rooms right next
to each other right yes and so we take
this sounds like a long time two hours
to get ready two hours hair and makeup
but we dance in the middle
i play music in between so we don't see
each other throughout that whole time
and when we come together by the end of
the two hours we look at each other in
the mirror and we go
yes you killed it we killed it wouldn't
change a thing no
scarlet's facetiming me your little
sister might be your little sister
we're recording get out of here
i got a sandwich okay bye
okay
are you kidding me
breaking the news scarlett gotta get a
sandwich
make a point about scarlett when we
facetime her we were just talking about
this the other day i was facetiming her
before getting ready and sistine was
watching scarlett doesn't talk to you
when she's facetiming you do what she
does she facetimes you and has 12 people
in the room she has conversations with
them so you're literally sitting on the
phone saying nothing trying to ask her
questions but she's talking to other
people so annoying anyway back to the
night sophie and i we come together we
go wow you're looking good i'm looking
good we're feeling good and we're like
we're gonna have a night yes it's gonna
be fun
but you know what it was was there has
to be a combination of things i know
we've talked about like the the perfect
night whatever the perfect storm of
feeling great but it really is like if
you're feeling good like we felt like
our outfits looked great our hair makeup
everything we put on fake tan
that was key that was key we actually
did look at each other that morning go
gotta put some value body on
it's a little pasty a little pacier but
we felt confident so honestly we didn't
feel like we had to i don't know
whenever i could get self-conscious
about what i'm wearing or how we look i
always think about that and then your
whole night is ruined because you're
thinking that everyone else is thinking
the same thing about yourself as you are
but and the reality of it is no one is
looking at you and they're just thinking
of themselves exactly but it's so true
having that mentality walking into the
room feeling good about yourself can
really change how the night plays out
and the craziest part is it's all a
matter of you yeah you're the one that
determines whether you're gonna have a
fun night at all well you know what it
was too was walking in so when we walked
into this place it was a bunch of people
that we knew from l.a it was like one of
those things honestly it felt like a
high school college elementary school
reunion
my worst night terrifying my worst
nightmare social anxiety to max but at
the same time i walked in going okay i
feel good but for some reason i even
said this since the scene she said it
too
we're we were on this like thing going i
don't give a [ __ ] when anyone thinks no
no no no
you were on that okay
you
sophia was on a world tour of just
roasting anyone that came in her
direction i i like to say as archer if
you guys watch show archer he goes
rampage that was me no you get two shots
in her and she will tell you to your
face how it is i have never for so i had
this wave i never do this i told my
friend the next day what i was doing and
she goes i've never seen you
ever call people out or just like say
whatever you want i'm always pretty
but that's the ironic part people look
at me and think that i would go up to
someone and just say it how did one of
us do really but you did but i did and
it was because i was in the moment going
you know what i'm not looking for a guy
i'm not looking to like i feel like i
look good i want to have a good time i
was just focused on that and when i tell
you
i bullied a guy into a date so i could
dance week and so that was one there
were people there that that were kind of
rude to me in the past and so i just
kind of it was your it was your
redemption story with all of them yeah
it was literally everybody that just
came up to me that was rude to me in the
past go oh you now you're talking to me
it was yeah you called it out it was
hard aggressive but if honestly
by the way
i don't know why but guys loved it
the ones i was roasting i think yeah you
guys like to be
you know do you guys teased a little
yeah like right you know what i think i
think it's sort of that that childhood
mentality of being you know a first
grader on the playground it's like when
a guy pushes you in the sandbox that
means he likes you well you know i think
it's also a sign of confidence is when
you can jokingly play around with
something and it's not forced like i
wasn't forcing being funny to people i
was just being i was like i don't really
care what i say i'm just gonna like
this one guy this one guy called himself
tall
and you just tore him up you're like oh
boy you just wanted to subtly throw in
that you're tall we get it you're tall
it's not a personality trait i was like
oh
that's always what i mean i had to walk
away but he did he did stalk the whole
night i said that see i'm like one shot
for every lake you get on tick tock oh
it was so it was brutal it was brutal
but it wasn't brutal because i thought
it was the funniest night ever and we
both came home and we're like
success success success you were funny
this morning too no yesterday you
screamed oh yeah this staircase
i had a i had a shower crisis
she did have shower courses it only
happens like once a year to me though
something always matters well i i'm done
and i hear
so fast
okay this is ice cream sophia
come upstairs help me and bring scissors
i was like
what the hell was she doing in the
shower that i need to bring scissors for
i was so confused
and so basically she also doesn't like
like i don't really care if she like
walks in on me i walk she hates when i
walk in on her yeah don't walk it on
this was like a rare rare so i'm
standing in the bedroom freezing
fresh out the shower and it looks like a
giant rat's nest is on the side of my
head
yeah she's like what happened
i was i brought a hairbrush in to the
shower and i know that's probably
not what you're supposed to do because
they're like oh it rips your hair out
because it's fragile when it's wet yeah
but whatever i brush my hair in the
shower okay sue me the bristle okay
sue me
i'll see you in court um the bristle got
caught in my earring
really bad
really bad where i was actually like
verge of bleeding i was pulling it so
hard so if you had to cut the hairbrush
out of my earring and there's actually
still you still have the dot i can't
take it out it's still in my earring why
don't you take the earring out the
hairbrush is now a part of me it's gonna
stay i can't i can't do anything
i got terrified i'm like what the hell
is she did she fall first i thought you
fell and then i heard scissors i'm like
i don't know what i'm walking into but
i'm glad you're safe and the earring is
still working you're like 16 use
manscaped we don't need scissors
um
oh so i talked to mom and dad this
morning oh yeah you said you had a
really good talk with you yeah i
actually like um my mom and i call each
other like either one of us call each
other every morning we kind of just sit
and have coffee together okay my mom's
sad and lonely can i make sure i gotta
interject sophia's the good daughter
because
you actually do call mom every single
day and you do your daughter duties does
anyone else out there just feel slightly
bad and they know it's a little bit
wrong that they don't call their parents
as much as they normally should but they
still don't even though they know it's
wrong
yeah so i try to do my part and act as
all three sisters thank you scholarly
you are the plug for that thank you but
i called mom this morning and dad told
him my dad was out of time so my mom was
just kind of alone now she's finally
reunited with her husband and so um i
was telling my mom about how i have a
date this week uh and my dad suddenly
comes out of nowhere and grabs the phone
and i don't know why but he was dropping
me some like golden nuggets
advice yeah i have to say sometimes he
is a shakespearean when it comes to
dating and it was so weird i don't know
where it came from because all i was
saying to my mom was saying like you
know like this guy's nice but i don't
really know if it's gonna like turn into
anything like i have a feeling and my
dad grabs funnies like can i just butt
in here and like say a couple things go
yeah sly what's up and i had to write it
down because actually i think it's a
really good reminder and susan you can
like also say the things i wrote down
here too to like add in but
he was saying about um
being patient for the right one and that
he first was saying the way that a guy
treats you early on in the dating life
whether it's like he's more forward with
like booking dates or if he's not if
he's more relaxed it really is an
indicator of how his overall personality
will be in the relationship so it's
dependent on you on whether or not
you're going to want that but then he
started going on and saying that it's
really important to not force a partner
and that
if he had not
forced his way into like love or dating
and things his roma like his love life
before my mom like now it works would
have been totally different i think what
you had mentioned uh to me this morning
that was so important was you have a
habit of
wanting to rush to find a good
relationship right now
and what was the advice that he gave you
about not
not rushing love and just waiting for it
to come out whatever like it's important
to know and wait who you are and he said
basically the magnetism and the energy
that you're putting out there will send
the best person towards you but this is
what he said key that i thought was
really interesting and i mean it's not
like something
super profound but i think it's a good
reminder that
it might be next week or when you're 35
years old but choose happiness and true
compatibility than chasing the clock
and he was like don't expect like a time
right don't expect like oh i need to
because like everyone else has a
boyfriend or everyone else is dating
like i need to date and he's like you
date 100 people you date one person it's
not going to change the right person
that will come into your life for you
he's like you also could find the love
of your life at 40 who cares
yeah i mean paris hilton just got mad
yeah exactly so it's just cool like he
just started talking all this stuff i'm
like slide i'm telling you you know what
we're gonna do another episode of sly
and we're gonna make it more dating
relationship
fatherly advice yeah and i think people
are gonna be shocked with how
you know knowledgeable he is about yeah
it because i think i mean he is a guy
and so he has like the guided
perspective but he also
is around all women and he really gets
like what we're expecting or what we
want he understands that women sometimes
we feel like oh we need to if we're not
married before 30 or having kids like
it's down look down upon but now i think
obviously today it's different but when
he was saying that he was like it
doesn't matter he could i know you know
what i do like his sort of wisdom i
think a lot of it has to do with the
fact that he is older and he's older
than most
dads that our friends or have have today
and i think that also comes with its old
school mentality which is what we were
raised on so that's why sometimes you
know like we had clint on last week and
he was like you need to
have a you have to tell the guy to court
you whereas we were raised with seeing
and hearing no the man is supposed to
court the women obviously times are
changing but i think it's really um
interesting having that perspective as
opposed to what we only see and know
being you know millennials and gen z
yeah so i i just like it's like one
thing i have to remember is like to not
chase the clock and just like chase yeah
what just focus on me and like then the
right person see okay because you also
go into every single date saying you
know there will never be a second date
i'm just doing it to be fun and whatever
and he said
don't waste your time dating a hundred
people because that's not going to
matter when you do find the one like
those hundred people are yeah but
sometimes
nights alone can be boring and you know
sometimes i want a dinner and i want to
kiss
sue me
i'll see you in court
you can't take my line i'll see you in
court see you in court hold on
get out of here take your finger out of
my
face
okay you guys we have a really exciting
guest on today her name is violet benson
aka
daddy issues which is something we all
have yeah she is the host of a podcast
called too tired to be crazy we had her
actually on the very first episode of
the online podcast she was episode one
it was uh we're bad at breakups yeah
classic classic because my ex-boyfriend
who
just recently broke up with that time
listened to that and that was
just experience
but we're really excited because she's
coming on and we're going to talk about
everything from dating what's going on
with her life and a lot more so stay
tuned
[Music]
okay you guys we are so excited to have
back on our very first guest that was
ever on the unwax podcast you might know
her from the popular meme instagram
daddy issues or her hilarious podcast
too tired to be crazy we have the sexy
hot firecracker violet benson in the
building
also
also
we'd like to say happy birthday happy
birthday oh my god that's so nice i
thought you guys forgot i don't know
this is not really okay
he's got a [ __ ] cake and a little gift
right here
and tequila so cake and tequila happy
birthday happy birthday
pretend to blow out lit candles yeah
this is the same tequila you guys got me
when i was a guest on your show but i
can't imagine you have it still it must
be finished
a year later i may still have it wow i'm
not a drinker
dude but you know what i think these
thank you so much of course they're good
they're good uh re-gifts
that's true
in case you have a guest on yours okay
is this a re-gift whatever you want oh
this is yours no no i'm saying did you
guys no are you guys were gifting me i
know we bring them for all of our guests
we've stuck with that for over a year i
love that same thing yeah what did you
do for your birthday
well i cried
oh why
well i don't know i kind of like cry a
lot of times with my birthday because
it's like i start to think about things
i didn't accomplish and then i'm like
then i have to start thinking of the
things i'm thankful for
did you wake up like this no no i just
this is also the first year where i
didn't plan something like normally i
plan stuff but it's always
every time i do a birthday ends up being
super stressful because everything i
plan is to make the people my life
really happy because i'm a planner and
i'm a perfectionist so then i'm always
super stressed and like throwing a party
or like a little event yeah or like even
if i'm creating massages forever and
whatever and then i pay for everything i
make sure everything's like it's always
free for everyone right so then i'm
always stressed and this is the first
year that i just didn't have the energy
and i was like i'm not gonna do anything
so i did randomly go to vegas with my
friends for like a day so i saw that on
your story i was gonna i wrote that down
like how was vegas because i saw your
story you didn't make it to the clubs
the one night you were there
because i like what was the plan like
you show up to vegas for one night with
your friend i forgot i don't like
clubbing
so right no
you went to vegas like club central i go
to vegas for one night yeah and
i felt bad for my friends because
they're like excited to hang out with me
but then like i ended up being late to
dinner well a our plane ended up like
the plane we booked ended up instead of
leaving an afternoon something got
canceled so we ended up having to go on
a different plane that was like 6 p.m
and then by we got to vegas we finally
checked into our rooms and then i end up
being late to dinner because i kind of
just like to take my time
and it's your birthday yeah so it's kind
of like late to dinner and then after
that
okay so since i don't drink alcohol i do
drink these drinks that have edibles in
them yeah oh okay and i instead of
drinking the small edible drink i drank
a larger edible drink oh and i got a
little too high so you got too high i
got super high and then whenever i want
to go to the club and i i get really
weird do you paranoid when you get high
yes i get paranoid and i not only do i
get paranoid but also like i ended up
realizing that was like the only quote
quote somewhat single girl in the group
so some of the girls had boyfriends they
were with them some of the girls have
boyfriends that just weren't with them
and then there was all these other guys
were with us who were single and i just
felt like they were like maybe it was my
paranoia i felt like they were staring
at me so whenever i get like we probably
look taught it was your birthday yeah no
i know you're vegas i'm really weird i
feel like as a woman you grew up
in a way where you constantly have to
look around to make sure that you're
safe so i have this really weird thing
where i actually don't like to get drunk
too drunk or drunk in general or even
high whatever in front of men i don't
know i just don't want to put myself in
a weird situation so at that point
edible ingested um is this when you
started crying
no i was fine i like okay i like i went
back to the room and then i changed into
my sweatpants like are you not coming
and i was like hey guys i don't know um
i'll see you guys there like don't worry
about me and then they left and then i
just started eating and i ordered uh i
ordered a movie
um and then within two seconds i fell
asleep i saw your story you're like hey
guys i'm not going to the club i'm too
high i'm just going to stay in tonight i
got so high that is funny what is
something that you learned this year
that you're going to take into next year
as you're getting older i think one
thing that i've learned this year um is
just
that i'm still learning i would say a
i feel like i've been growing a lot as a
person like i've been
continuously growing but one thing that
i am trying to learn more and more this
year is probably to be like easier on
myself because i think like i definitely
have a hard time with it and i feel like
we all try a lot of us do try to gross
people but we don't know how to handle
it if we feel like we're digressing like
suddenly like we self sabotage we do
something and and it hap and the minute
that happens we're like
[ __ ] i messed up like i'm a [ __ ] up or i
guess i didn't change the person versus
like that's actually
we don't realize that there's no such
thing as a path like forward there's all
these moments you're gonna go backwards
no matter how much you're trying because
that is part of growing right it's you
being self-aware oh this happened
how do i handle it and keep moving
forward yeah and like i still have those
moments where if i digress i'm just like
i'm such a failure like blah blah so i
feel like
like on my birthday and that's like one
thing that i've been trying to work on
and learn is to be a little easier on
myself just the same way i would tell my
friends to be easy on themselves yeah
yeah sometimes we give our friends the
best advice that we don't ever listen to
ourselves and i i honestly agree with
that there's not one right way to go
about life and there's not one right
time that you're supposed to be
successful in your career and there's
not one time you're supposed to get
married or be in a relationship so i
mean i do the same thing i feel like a
birthday is either great for someone or
it's extremely reflective and i just
constantly think of all of the things
that i could have done at this time
yeah something that
you were like oh [ __ ] like this is
something i wanted to get done but i i
didn't get the chance to do it
um i wouldn't say it was one thing but i
do think like even as we're sitting here
and i'm thinking about it like i think i
do remember someone telling me maybe it
was my mom that a while back she told me
like
you got to remember like today is the
youngest you'll ever be so if you sit
there
every time and you're just like ugh
another birthday or i don't want to
celebrate this i don't want that then
it's just like you're missing out right
and a beautiful day and then it's now
just a memory yeah like every day is the
youngest you'll ever be in that moment
oh my gosh i think it's important to
celebrate a birthday even if it's small
i think it's a good time to celebrate
you and it feels honestly i know people
hate their birthday but sometimes it's a
good reminder of how much people do care
about you and love you then when you get
people to reach out and you also are
like i'm alive another year like i have
another opportunity to like have a whole
other year of like new memories new
though because i feel like i do reflect
on the people i dated or the decisions i
made and the career choices i've done
and it's like okay like why don't i just
be positive about it because yeah you're
what your mom said it's the youngest
you'll be so celebrate i mean yeah
celebration although i do think next
year have your friends throw your
birthday for you yeah so you don't have
to deal no they would not do it as good
as i feel like you're all i know she's
so much like me i planned my birthday to
a tea like i
love for it to be perfect on all angles
and i know it will be fun if i it's not
even for you it's just for your friends
it's for my friends
yeah i like my friends i'll be like i'll
just do it i'll figure like well after
that vegas which didn't fully work out
even the next day like we went to brunch
and afterwards everyone wanted to go
shopping and i was like hey guys i'm
going to go back to the room to lay down
yes so like i really just came to vegas
to sleep and eat and have your friends
go out to cabin
then the next day i spent it with my
family which was nice and my dad got me
this like sick puzzle that i've been
wanting to do it's like a 3d puzzle oh
super cool and then yesterday which was
my actual
birthday november 15. it was a day where
i actually worked first i worked
although i do like everything you just
said like i am i feel like i'm going to
go home and like start writing things
down like yeah it is nice to remember
like the things that you've done in the
past like who you've dated like i have a
journal i write all the time in and i
seriously i told to see them like it's
really fun just to write the one date i
went on i like that yeah i think i'm
gonna do that but like okay here's an
example about me planning versus my
friends one of my friends had an event
yesterday and i said you know what screw
this i'm not doing anything i'll come to
your event and she's like well i want to
celebrate you so i'm going to get you a
cake she had a whole week to get me a
cake i came up with the idea for the
cake because she couldn't because she
was too busy then
i'm like yo did you even get the cake
and then she like didn't have time to
get the cake i ended up calling the cake
plate because i was like i don't even
want to do it anymore and she bought
your no but i want to celebrate i
buy my own cake i call them to order my
own cake put on rush buy my own cake
then have to email them what to print on
it
which already was [ __ ] enough
because it made me feel like a loser to
be honest because i didn't even want to
do it right right i show up to her event
she's not even organized enough to
figure out like when to even present the
cake to me where to put it and so it
wasn't until my friend goes up to him
like yo it's like what's the deal with
the cake like whatever then um and it
was like already towards the end where
people are starting to leave
so then she finally remembers to send
the cake to me and then she presents the
cake to me and i just honestly i felt
like not humiliated because no actually
knows what's happening but i was like
great like i already feel like [ __ ] and
you just made me feel even more like
honestly that is a really good sign that
that's not a really good friend yeah
that's obviously because like 100
percent right i feel like this year and
i even say this is 16 like you only need
one friend like i this she's like my
best best friend but in general like i
realized how many friends even after
quarantine i'm like we're not really
that genuine we cut out so many people
from our life because yeah it's true you
take moments like that and that shows
who's actually gonna show up for you and
who won't and
ninety percent of the people that you
thought were going to don't but even on
your podcast remember we brought up like
we're not getting any names but remember
someone that you thought was your friend
like spoke badly about you yeah and
you're like i was so nice to you there i
like invited you over my house it's and
then you still talk [ __ ] it's like what
do you do in that scenario do you just
like do you confront or do you just let
it slide under there so we talked about
how with that one person you and i had a
conversation yeah
i didn't confront that person right but
we were never we didn't we weren't that
close with this certain person
i was gonna either i was upset then i
was just like trying to go think of all
the therapy in my brain i'm like always
kind of putting on me well i must be
projecting because i feel low and that's
why and then and then my friend's like
no v
if you're hanging out with other people
and none of those people make you feel
low and telling you hang out with one
specific person that person does give
you that feeling something's wrong like
there's something there pay attention
it's not always just you and how you
feel about yourself and i was like that
is a really good point and i did start
to think about it more and more exactly
i think this is a really important
lesson for a lot of people listening
that sometimes they feel as if they have
to stay in a friendship with someone
because it's oh i don't have any other
options and that they're my only friend
but
you've got to be selfish in that
situation i would rather be alone than
spend time with a quote unquote friend
that wouldn't even
show up for my birthday exactly yeah
it's not worth it it's like also time is
so short like you're going to waste time
and have all this toxic energy around
you when the more you let a boyfriend
treat you like that well no i feel like
no more so i feel like the more shitty
people you have around you the shittier
your life and the decisions you are
going to be like it's just you know what
i'm saying like it's like a tracks like
so get rid of that like you don't need
her and of course it could be projection
of course it can come from insecurities
but why
should we put up with other people's
insecurities if they can't figure it out
it's a fine line to to teeter with
because it is important to be
sympathetic to people but it's so hard
to remember that when they're putting
you down and you're you're taking it
personal but it's projection i don't
think i wouldn't say it
i don't believe it's from a malicious
place at all like i don't view it in
that type of light at all but i do think
i think
sometimes
people pretend like they want you to sit
at their table
but they don't actually want you to sit
at their table they may want to be the
only woman in that table
right or
whatever it is and that's just the truth
and it takes me sometimes a while to see
things until my other friends will kind
of be like hey sure but i think it's
also important to note that you're you
can talk to her and you could bring this
up and say like you know what i've known
you for this long if it's like worth if
it's a friendship that's worth
reviving okay well
then then
onwards
next year we'll try it again no we got
you a cake yeah it's a little funky i
won't replace you thank you thanks
violet i do have to say that the first
time that i met you
i was a little shook in my boots uh you
were kind of you were
and i think it's
i kind of admire it in a lot of ways
because
you were really powerful and strong and
it's cool to see a woman like that very
just like forward but at the same time
it was very intimidating and i was like
whoa oh my god oh my gosh i don't think
he liked me i don't think he likes me
either
that was the first impression really
yeah people always tell me that that's
not like i think it just takes me a
second to soften up like i am a very
soft sweet person but i think i think it
has to do
i know it sounds silly but i do think it
has to do with the
not language barrier but the culture
difference because i'm russian mm-hmm
right so we're russian i and i'm also
israeli so like we're just the way
my culture is we're direct right it's
not like americans
it's just i think with america it's
always and it's and especially also
women women
yeah also the way we're raised
is to always ask for permission to
always be more timid and all that and
we're the princess we're getting saved
we're not the one doing the savings so i
think
when there's that's where the culture of
difference comes in where for me i
believe coming i also come from
corporate america yeah from public
accounting so for me i've learned if you
want something ask if you're not getting
it you're asking the wrong person well
yeah she came up with purple hair and i
was like oh my god you you like were so
much because we were just starting
podcasting and so you were a veteran in
this like you knew exactly what to do
what to say there was a part um we did
shoot an episode with you that never
aired which was kind of funny because i
remember when you did your intro and
outro you were so good at it and so on
it and i was like really she knows how
to do to do that you were just like
we're excited like what you normally do
like thank you guys like thank you daddy
like i'll see you next week and we
thought that was the coolest thing
that's so nice
that's the that's the thing like when i
started my podcasting and i was
listening to myself speak there was a
lot of things i didn't like about about
it i was mumbling a lot i was saying a
lot of alms i was speaking too slow i
sometimes i was too robotic and i had to
kind of change my tone so that's
literally what saved me from having
social anxiety this is why i don't have
social anxiety it's kind of this reminds
me from high school when i would have
social anxiety i started going to high
school parties by myself and people that
was really weird and it was because i
having
it was because
that would give me more anxiety no i
know it was because i have anxiety that
i was like this is how i'm going to
overcome it right i started showing up
to events from like to parties by myself
so then i was forced to start talking to
new people and it was just this one
moment i remember one time somebody came
up to me and they were like wow that's
so cool like you're s it's so cool
you're so confident you can just like
talk to people and go to parties with
myself and i was looking at this person
thinking that's crazy because i thought
you were so cool and that's when it hit
me wow everyone else is so insecure just
like me if not more true yeah and no
one's thinking about me they're all
they're busy thinking about themselves
in their own institutions said that
right before you came on so it's the
same thing like i came on your podcast
you guys are sitting there like wow like
the way she did her intro ultra like you
had no idea that maybe i wasn't that
proud of her like i didn't know what i
was doing because you were just focusing
on
my my strengths or whatever what you
thought was what was your first
impression of us
i thought you guys were really nice but
um
not but i thought you guys be honest i i
love this go ahead we're here we're here
no i i mean obviously it's like day and
night from when you guys first started
the podcast versus yeah it's totally
different we were very innocent but it's
not the yes it's not the actual podcast
it's like how you felt in your skin
no it's true i feel like the more you
you do this like i think the things i
would have said back then i would have
never done what i've done today like the
things that about sex dating boys like
even like my personal issues yeah i
don't think i would have ever felt
comfortable if i hadn't done it for at
least a year
a hundred percent the second episode i
ever recorded for my podcast was with
this one girl that ended up getting
taken down and just to show you how much
inexperience i was as well and i'm still
learning was
it was right after coachella and she
came on my show and instead of me
interviewing her i started to interview
her and then somebody got about
coachella and i started talking about
like
i took molly and then i had a nervous
breakdown and then i started crying
about it and then it was just me talking
the whole time and it wasn't even about
her and then we obviously took the
episode down but people were upset
because they're like
a good guest are you interviewing your
guest
sitting next to you the whole time
yeah so it's just you know most people
don't know what they're doing is my
whole point and everyone has to start
somewhere i think that's something that
we need to learn is we always look at
people like wow they're so good at what
they do whether it's in finance or nfts
or podcasting or whatever it is but
everyone starts at the same point yeah
and it's i think it's really cool like
you've grown so much in your podcast but
seeing our development as well um
especially sitting with you now 57
8 episodes later i know it's pretty full
circle and when i met you guys i was
like wow they're so pretty i look like
[ __ ] today like ugh
next to that funny that is i felt so
horrible about the way i looked that
down oh my hair is fried and it's orange
and it's crunchy and like my makeup is
cakey but again it goes back to like
no one actually know like you were
looking at me like oh they look pretty
whereas i'm looking at myself like the
exact opposite that's why i think
confidence either faking it or or really
feeling it
i mean it really just changes the whole
energy of like how you're gonna perform
that day yeah and i was like oh they're
so pretty they're so perfect like how am
i even gonna be able to like relate to
them i bet like they you know you just
get in your head and just like and it's
just funny so you guys got in your head
i got my head and then the reason the
episode wasn't released i actually don't
even recall why but it had nothing to do
with me not liking you guys i liked you
guys i was just like i probably can't
relate to them or something we don't
have to release it we did a reading
it's a lot better it's coming out on
hers but it's just funny how we've all
like throughout the year like we've all
become closer and yeah like we actually
talked about on her show but you like
gave us the worst setups of all time or
gave me the worst setup of all time yeah
violet loves to regurgitate her
old dates onto yeah she basically told a
guy she wanted to get rid of to date me
and she threw him on me and he was like
the weirdest person i text i was like
who is this guy he won't leave me alone
she doesn't know that oh no i just
wanted to bother me so i gave him to you
well i thought that made just because
we're not imagine doesn't mean they
can't be a match okay i understand that
he's a tourist she's a virgo
did not okay too much that was too much
for me he was answering everything
there was something off about him and
after he after he did dm you two truths
one lie i was like oh i messed up that's
just that it's not mad it's almost like
when a guy goes truth or dare you're
like what what
it's like let's play 20 questions what
are we in eighth grade i know you know i
just i can't i feel like sometimes
texting like it really is a
i don't know for me like an indicator of
how you're going to be not in person but
like
i don't if you're not like you'll answer
questions i would love i would love your
opinion on how do you feel about
receiving a voice note from a guy oh i
love them oh i send voice notes all the
time we told our listeners to never send
a voice note why
because it's horrible why why do i
listen to you talk for four minutes
voice notes are so much better because a
it saves you from screenshots
so like if i'm actually irritated
but you can they can save your voice now
yes but it's just it's different because
p it's so much easier because then the
person have it's it's so much more
difficult people love to now have
receipts and all that and like if i'm
mad and actually i'm to communicate how
mad i am i usually
will send a voice note to express myself
because it's much harder to then prove
that i'm crazy yeah then you have to
like screen record but
yeah i would do
you get the you leave her crumbs like
you can't like leave your comments see
now that's making me rethink everything
do you think they sent me voice notes so
that it would expire and i couldn't send
it out no no but like i like voice notes
like i actually like hearing the guy's
voice and vice versa oh i hate it that's
the part i don't like i hate it okay so
horrible hinge had this new update
recently where you can answer the
questions that they have pre-written for
you with a voice actually those have
been pretty funny and they're like
blowing up on tick tock and it's
actually hysterical because guys are
saying the weirdest oh
yeah
girls are posting it to make fun of them
because they sound so strange no i
didn't do the voice notes on the app but
like i like i send voice notes to guys
all the time
and i like face timing too
oh
yeah i do love like a a drive-by just
like don't even let them know face time
but how soon is too soon to face time
would you facetime before the first date
i think you should 100 percent
because you kind of especially if it's a
blind date in a way where you've never
been in real life because you never know
like what if you end up like i've made
the mistake before in the past to not
facetime and then we meet up and you're
like ha
you are nothing like the text because in
text you have time to be to think about
the text message
or someone helped you now in real life
like oh you we do not get along yeah
like you are so boring once you're in
red flags when you're texting or
facetiming someone that immediately
you're like i can't go out with you okay
there was a red flag with this one guy
that i didn't even realize
and until i asked my friends about it
there was this one guy we were
facetiming
a good amount of times and a lot of
times would be evening time because of
our time difference because he was in a
different state and
when we would be in bed he would have a
shirt off and i didn't realize that okay
literally i'm the only one that missed
the red flag
no but that's like an invisible flag no
it's a red flag because he's a wuss and
instead of trying to get sexual with me
he kind of it was like a way of implying
waiting for me because he that's just
kind of how he was as a person in
general like waiting for me to to apply
things
and until i mentioned to someone they're
like wait why is the shirt off every
time like was it hot though was it good
no sophia i felt nauseous every time and
it made me uncomfortable and i didn't
realize that also meant that i'm
sexually not attracted to it wait i
honestly
you're like
naked body was making me nauseous if i
saw that i would have been like oh it's
just like he doesn't wear a shirt to go
to bed that's what i thought until i i
mentioned someone else and they're like
that's so inappropriate like they're
like how are you were you wearing a
sweatshirt i'm like yeah i was wearing
clothes like then he can put a shirt on
you guys have never met you've never had
sexual encounters why is he did you pull
him out
no because eventually i i got a little
board with him anyway and i do you get
bored easily with guys
no so maybe yeah
no maybe yeah yeah
i don't know i actually something really
crazy that i realized yesterday i was
talking about my producer
that i always thought a lot of the time
with men that
they're playing me or something and then
i've noticed there's a pattern of the
same words that every guide says to me
it's like one sentence what is it the
balls in your court oh
and i didn't realize the pattern and i
was like wait why did they all say that
we had a guest on last week and that was
my entire
argument was i hate when guys put the
ball in my court keep it in your
freaking court i don't want to be
playing tennis i want a soccer player
we're not playing the ball it pisses me
[ __ ] basketball oh my especially in
the early stages like why is it in my
court i don't even know what i'm gonna
ask for it i'm like so we're over what
court yeah are we what ball what ball
yeah how many balls are in this game how
many players are playing is it a two are
we playing hand ball like what is it
tether balls it makes me feel better no
there's like balls in your court it's
like no but really what does that mean
it doesn't mean you're too
wuss to say what you want and you don't
want to be rejected if i don't feel the
same way so you're like oh i want to
protect my feelings no say what you want
yeah do they say balls in your court in
terms of like
where to go next or like in terms of
like where to go on a date or is it just
in general like they'll just no i think
it's just because i'll be like i like
you wait never mind okay wait let's do
this wait maybe let's hold off without
realizing and then suddenly sometimes i
end up self sabotaging by
creating a story in my brain because
sometimes you know there can be a gap in
communication yeah even if you don't
speak for a day or two randomly yeah and
so you could ask your partner by
communicating be like hey what have you
been up to your last two days yeah
right
call them pick up the phone call them or
you can sit there and be like oh
i didn't hear for them for two days
because they probably have a wife and um
so that brings up a funny point
yeah you're sort of seeing no i'm not
hold on i i recall you came into the
studio and said well i haven't heard
from this person in two days and your
brain's going all right no my brain is
not going to wacko with this person
she's already went wackos what did you
do because you said yeah what's
happening what did you do
she's like that is embarrassing for me
i messed it up by getting in my head
and
it was like push and pull but like only
on my end so this person's just there
and you'd be like oh okay okay and in my
brain i start to think maybe he's
playing maybe that and really he was
just going with the flow with what i
wanted so he was just going
i'm like i want something casual i don't
i can't do something casual just be
friends okay actually no like we should
date okay no it's too casual and it's
just like that's all embarrassing so
much a lot of girls go through that
there was ups no well i haven't gotten
to them oh yeah i feel like the ball has
to drop oh that's fine i think i've done
it so like it was and then we like
hung out
that day before you guys came to record
my podcast and it was fine and suddenly
oh yeah you remember i told you guys
that i sent him those like texts or
whatever about like you know what i was
actually thinking about it and i didn't
like when you did this and then yeah and
then i was like yeah you were savage
that was one thing i like to note is
that she's super direct about if
something is like yeah
you're like the best communicator no i'm
not
communicator is when you're there face
to face the worst way to communicate my
way in my opinion is when it's an attack
mode and it's also an attack like that's
not communicating you have to say it in
the moment you can't say it like yeah
later and you have to say
you have to have to be more positive i
mean i teach about this but then i do
completely the opposite
yeah so like yeah i did express how i
feel but that was already in my opinion
like a little down like it was
unnecessary because again he was just
going off of what he thought i wanted
okay and then i'm getting upset over
small things that wasn't getting in my
head was it more that you were sort of
doing this cat mouse chase and then when
he wouldn't chase you like you were
chasing him you'd be like i wasn't
chasing him oh you know what i mean it's
almost like when you're teasing someone
and then they roast you back and you're
like what the [ __ ] no
oh when we were hanging out or i don't
know oh yeah it's like i make a joke
then he made a joke back and i was like
what the [ __ ] was that
exactly i do what's the reason then that
you guys so like after that i think i
felt like i wonder if he's dissing with
me and i was like oh he's listening with
me like one day if you lost interest i
can't do casual like what was i thinking
like trying to do casual like i'm gonna
end up liking this guy i'm so stupid i
can't do this like oh my god i'm gonna
get her and it was like all these
thoughts and then this is how dramatic i
am now i feel so embarrassed i hope he
never hears this he won't
okay cool he's on social media so he
will no he's on social media i love that
um
i sent him this text because i'm like
overly dramatic and overly poetic and i
was like
hey i've been thinking i can't do casual
and by the way if i was like i want to
be you to be romantic with me he would
probably done it like that's how well
really so instead i'm like i can't do
casual i i need romance not this it
doesn't make me feel good you don't make
me feel good which i shouldn't have said
i didn't mean it like that and i was
like you don't make me feel good you
meant the situation yeah exactly yeah i
was like it doesn't make me feel good
you don't make me feel good i want this
to stop i'm sorry i can't we'll always
have new york and it was like so
dramatic so unnecessary and i'm very
well put i'll give you this
and he's not understanding the syllables
he'll always have new york he doesn't
respond then i'm like oh [ __ ] all right
then the next dad we hear from him and
i'm like interesting it was like even if
i'll never hear from this person again
the thought that i just accidentally
made someone feel bad about themselves
and i'm not going to explain myself and
i especially because i feel like
everyone's going through something well
that's true that goes back to our
conversation earlier it's like how
you're feeling internally sometimes you
project it on other people and it wasn't
meant to come off that way yeah and i
don't know what he's going but he also
doesn't know what you're going through
he doesn't know you well enough to know
that the way you put things isn't really
as at all as it seems like you have your
emotions with things like if he knew you
really knew yeah you know okay like
she's actually someone that is like a
loyal person like she's a romantic
person she likes relationships she likes
being more intimate with some people's
histories too play a big part into how
they're dating today i had a bad habit
when i was first seeing the person i'm
with
and i would compare him to all of my
horrible
ex-boyfriends
and i would say well they did this to me
so i'm expecting him to do this to me
i'm living with him yeah yeah even
though he would show no signs of doing
that and he was great i'd be like well
it's bound to happen because it's
happened every single time and my mom
said to scene you cannot compare this
guy to how other men treated you because
that's just also not fair to him
so it's really hard to sort of switch
that mentality and i'm still going
through it today i'm like when's the
ball going to drop i'm like how about i
just let it ride naturally you know also
though is that you i feel like you and i
are kind of similar with this like i
have a lot i'm i kind of create
scenarios i make a joke like i create
fake scenarios in my head and hurt my
own feelings like i literally think like
things are happening when they're not
happening and i realize with my
personality like i don't think i could
do like a casual relationship i don't
think i can be that person i will fall
for you like yeah
i have a very hard exterior but when i
am like connected to someone i get very
emotional and like and i won't admit it
though why did you want to even start
the relationship with the casual note
because i
she's 30 flirty and thriving it's
it's because
i went to new york
and i decided i was gonna have a
one-night stand
okay and i oh my gosh is this okay
samantha jones yes it was my first one
i'd stand i haven't had sex in a year
and a half
and he was just someone i picked based
on his looks right and i was like i'll
never see this person again
it doesn't matter that's always how it
starts
we met up he does it he didn't know that
was my plan i like met up with him and
his friends i was like hilarious
obviously she was like i was just
killing them without killing it because
and it was honestly that's actually one
of my
the question was about
like rose moment
that is actually one of my favorite
moments this year because it was like it
was that one day that was completely
able to be myself like i wasn't thinking
about how to say what to say and i
wasn't because i was just like i'll
never see this person again so i was
100 myself it was like one of the first
times i felt like because it's so hard
for me to open up to people right right
except obviously my five million
audience but accept those people
yeah no but like i'm kidding like even
even when you're an influencer and you
do what you do for a living the reason i
like to do this is because i'm still in
control of what i
can put out there that's actually how it
feels for us like we're very vulnerable
in our podcast but yeah we can control
that we're nice to people when we meet
them when we go out but i we even said
this weekend was probably the i mean for
me the first time i've felt like i don't
give a [ __ ]
that's a really interesting thing you
just said
the fact that you said i'm never going
to see these people again so i've never
acted more myself yeah and then they
responded
wonderfully for you being yourself yeah
what does that mean
it's not just that it's us getting in
our heads and uh suddenly when we go on
a date we're like what does this mean
and we start thinking of all these
things and then when you're like i'll
never see this person again so you could
just say exactly all your thoughts all
your opinions you can be as loving as
you want it doesn't matter if they like
it or not because you're just in the
moment and you'll never see them again
and that was how my brain worked and it
was a beautiful moment for me right
because it was so nice to just let go of
needing to be in control because you
know what it's like to be in control
so we ended up bonding that whole day
and like having sex the whole day and
just opening up and i remember i even
told them that like during after
the second time we slept together that
day or like we're talking and we're
cuddling my brain egg was like
[ __ ]
like i [ __ ] up
why did i sleep with this man because my
whole rule is like you don't sleep with
someone you like oh so you oh we
basically regretted it because of the
like that you've no because she went
into it thinking because i can't expect
my brain she's like all these littles
and she's breaking all these rules do
what makes you feel good i do still
believe for the most part
regardless you do need to get to the
emotional connection before you get to
the physical connection and had he had
an instagram
i think the only reason i didn't fully
go crazy is because he doesn't have an
instagram that i can stop and see who
he's adding about that actually i feel
like it makes my life
because i
do my very best to not stop because i
know i'll spin myself out
but we have shared a very strategic
clever
stalking techniques on the show sophia
is actually the cia
and she can find anything do you have
any yeah really tips for me actually do
you have any good tips that no
have you heard of any of these stupid
updates and like every time i come up
with a new stocking method they do an
update and they clear that like yeah and
it actually pisses me off what was a
good old one well the following like you
can see like well i can still do
one good stalking method that i still
have is because since i have a meme
account daddy issues i have i use extra
apps in order to download videos from
instagram so that special app where i
download videos on instagram i am able
to see people's stories without them
knowing i'm seeing their story that is
oh wow i didn't realize you could do
that yeah smart i know because it's hard
to do like a rogue account and then you
look at someone sorry they're well who
is this like this is bad because i used
to use my finsta not knowing that my
email and number is associated to the
main account but they find it well you
can you can see if someone like think
about if you're if you're my email
account
that is constantly like
watching your story i mean but they
don't notice well that's it we have a we
have a lot of followers where we can
yeah do you think guys
notice or like no look at this guys i
mean if they have like maybe 100
followers like they could probably
notice that someone i did
one time i saw i stopped talking to this
guy and i
accidentally
was scrolling through something and
accidentally pressed follow on his
account and then i quickly unfollowed
for my fensta and then he didn't
understand who it was and he clicked to
follow requested to follow me and i was
just like
should i
follow me but we stopped talking at this
point i think he like hated me and i was
like okay whatever maybe i'll let him
follow me maybe maybe he knows it's me
oh my god and he wants me back i allowed
him to follow me and then he unfollowed
me within two seconds oh
so then then he was just like oh [ __ ]
so you are a stalker and never mind i
don't want to follow you oh
god i mean i feel like yeah that
happened a couple of months ago it's
cool oh geez you know honestly i feel
like there's so many times where i
thought i was being sneaky and i'm
really not and now they all know that
yeah like i like to just keep talking
it's not like i'm stalking it's like to
know what's going on oh wait i would
like to say one good thing is
back to that one guy i was talking about
yeah i did end up being the bigger
person when i flew back from vegas the
minute i flew back from vegas i sent him
a voice note so and it made me realize
like i really created all the drama this
person was giving me space because you
thought i needed to figure things out
and sometimes when
you think you're doing the right thing
for that person they're receiving it as
the exact opposite like there have been
so many times where i was like oh like
bye and then this guy i'm seeing goes
well you didn't give me like a kiss
goodbye so honestly i thought that was
the last time i was gonna see you and i
was like whoa what like that that wasn't
what i thought there's times where i
didn't answer someone's text message
because i thought it was just like a
dead text message and they're like you
never respond to something somebody
likes me like and so but i think we
forget
with men that they also have
insecurities like i think as much as we
wanna it's like we know they do but i
think we sometimes forget and we're just
or both genders or whomever you're
talking to like sometimes we only think
of our own feelings and being vulnerable
which is so scary and we forget the
other person is also getting in their
head yeah so like he was giving me space
so i can figure my [ __ ] out and i was
like oh he's losing interest like i'm
just like gonna back off right yeah i
think the learning lesson here is take
things for face value and don't read too
much into it when you have absolutely no
idea what is going on in the other
person's life because you're gonna
completely ruin it when you think it
being about you know because there are
circumstances where you see people that
have stopped each other before and they
end up actually finding a connection
dating i know i know and it's like we
have these rules something like there's
no right way to do it right away no but
you know what my friend said that made
me feel so much better she goes you
always do this thing where you think
it's so poetic to walk away and you want
the man to chase you but she goes v
trust me you don't want to end up with a
guy who doesn't take rejection well and
chases you that's the guy you it's
actually a red flag that you don't want
to be with you need to stop thinking
that every person has to fight for you
before you let them in because a lot of
these good men are just going to walk
away because they're trying to be
respectful to what you ask them to do
and it's the man that doesn't listen
if you tell somebody i'm done with you
and they don't listen that's actually a
big red flag because it is they're not
respecting your boundaries
that's actually a really good way to put
it right because we make it it feels so
wrong
i'm like oh why didn't he and this is
just my own thing it's like why didn't
he reach out again like after like why
didn't you chase me through airport
security and meet me on the the tarmac
of the plane but so we said guys we
don't want who end up chasing us we're
always like ew stop like you're like
i'll never give up on you and you're
like i wish you would so basically our
brains are you won't be able to figure
them out not at all yeah but i was like
can we start over and he was like yeah
clean slate of course oh good
have you ever been cheated on
yeah of course obviously really isn't
everyone no yeah
really what me only no you did good guys
you probably got cheated on i just don't
know i'm kidding
no i hope not but i feel like i would
have caught them because do you still um
do you still hold uh
any emotions or sadness from those guys
cheating on you no i feel like i don't i
i feel like i've let it go but then who
knows if something triggers me and i
react a certain way but
to be honest i'm so oblivious to things
all the time i feel like i'm always like
even now to this day if i'm dating a guy
and it's the beginning stages and i find
out they're talking to someone else i'm
every time i'm shocked my friend's
always like are you serious you're
literally dating other people and i'll
still be like wait what
she was talking to someone else
always like the only person without your
friends that always sort of told you
they were cheating or how did you find
out that they were cheating well i had a
boyfriend off for like eight years oh my
gosh so
they cheated like what did they do i
think there was like a lot of really
obvious signs but i think deep down i
just didn't want to know i think i think
sometimes the more i've been that type
of person where i secretly rather not
know than knowing because once you know
then you have to deal with it and i
think
secretly i just didn't want to know but
there was a lot of really obvious
obviously signs like one time he was
like
hey remember that dick pic i sent you
can you send it back to me and i was
like
wait why
and he's just like just send it i just i
want to look at it and i was like he's
like it looked really good it looked
really big in that picture i just sent
it back to me and i was like that's a
really weird way kind of something sort
of similar kind of happened to me
actually what a guy asked you for back
first no no but in sort of the same
ballpark i was talking to this guy and i
was like oh my god i think we have so
much in common i think this is going to
be a great relationship we were talking
for like two months and all this stuff
and i was telling my girlfriend about it
i was like oh my god look at this guy so
cute and talented and blah blah and
she's like oh my god i have a picture of
his penis do you want to see it and i go
how
and why and why she goes oh he sent it
to me and another girl in a group chat
but it's so funny lol look how funny
this is it's so funny and i was like
okay show me
so
so she showed me and like in this group
chat he was being so
raunchy like so dirty so raunchy making
all these sexual things
but like
the person that i was talking to would
never do that was innocent was basically
a male snow white was just like the
greatest guy ever and then on this flip
side i was like who am i dating like who
is this person it was crazy so what did
you do
i went on a date with him i no this is
after
i ghosted him
and then
actually i wasn't going to but my dad
said the best words are no words spoken
so
the message came off much clearer than
anything that i would have been able to
articulate over text so
he was sending voice notes i was not
responding to the video they sent a
three minute
video propped up with like perfect car
lighting
i don't look that good he's like i get
it if i'm not cute
shut up
shut up that was the funniest video i've
ever seen i'm so happy to have that in
my camera roll forever thank you i hope
but yeah it was i didn't even respond to
the video like well i feel like i mean i
feel like obviously made the right
decision but i do wonder i mean you
can't really hold
no there's
the funny thing is that wasn't even why
i ended it oh okay yeah no that was just
um
a little
yeah so with my ex when he was like send
me back my dick pic and i was like no
and he's like v i'm literally going to
break up with you like are you serious
right now i was like oh my god please
don't break up with me here's the dick
pic and i sent him well i feel like so
many times or one time he was just like
do you want to hang out i was like no
i'm too tired he was like okay i'll just
hang out with nagin who was my best
friend at the time and i was like but
it's 12 a.m like why do you guys have to
hang out you're just like are you
serious are you really going to be this
jealous you know how do you know how
unattractive that is i was like i just
think it's weird that you want to hang
out with my best friend at 12 a.m like
what are you guys gonna do and i'd be
like okay fine or like one time i didn't
answer his phone call this one night
because we had a disagreement
and then i was just like so then we
didn't speak for a day or two and i was
like oh cool like we'll totally we're
just taking space and then i see on like
facebook that like he's in palm springs
with his ex-girlfriend and i was like
wait did you are you cheating on me and
he's like i thought we broke up huh and
i was like because i'd answer your calls
like i thought that was enough and then
again my brain i was like well i guess
technically that is like breaking up so
it wasn't cheating that honestly happens
so much where the boyfriend will start
being attracted to your girlfriends
i've heard so many stories of my friends
like their boyfriend was sending photos
of you know the girl her girlfriends are
like there's this whole thing on tick
tock where
have you seen that one channel where
they throw the marker into the glass oh
yeah if i do this the one girl walked up
to the glass put it and goes
now you got to stop calling my boyfriend
why are you calling my boyfriend so much
and she's like how did you know and he
goes oh it was crazy it was real what
would you do point being what would you
do if your boyfriend was talking to your
girlfriends do you get mad at your
friends or do you get mad at the guy i
would stop talking to both of them yeah
do you think about that
um
we were on and off
like this all started from beginning 20.
so this isn't like something that
happened like a year ago it's when like
i'm 30 i just turned 33 yesterday like
this happened when i was
20 21
but i would say one of the funniest
stories when we first started dating i
cuz i i would never like even ask
questions like i think i just
just happy someone liked me because you
know my daddy issues and of course i
picked the perfect emotionally
unavailable man who will never love me
but it was like always gave me crumbs
and uh there's a lot of things i liked
about him uh because he reminded me a
bit of my dad
so no we all did anyway
but like i remember he sometimes would
go to vegas and i didn't really hear
from him so i remember like he went to
vegas he came back and he was like oh my
god i missed you so much like i can't
wait like and we're about to like hook
up or whatever and then he's just like
oh my god sometimes actually felt like
he wanted me to catch him that was the
weird yeah he used to prank me that he
was cheating on me just to see my
reaction it was so weird because he was
cheating on me wait so anyway well he
goes to vegas he came back from vegas he
was like i'm just so excited to finally
to finally see who's like it's so funny
like it's so funny when you remember
when i was in vegas and you like sent me
that text about like you left your
underwear in my house nicole was like
what is that she got so freaked out and
i was like wait now call your
ex-girlfriend he goes yeah and i was
like oh she was in vegas too because oh
yeah i didn't tell you we ran into her
and i was like oh oh okay cool
wait how does she know about the text he
goes oh she like she went through my
phone and i was like okay cool wait why
did she go through your phone well her
phone turned off and like she needed to
charge it so she was just charging in my
room and like so then she i like passed
out she was going through my phone i was
like oh cool wait why did you pass out
he goes oh my god because i was just
taking a nap it's not a big deal so then
she went through my phone it was just he
was just over traumatizing her situation
but it was just also obvious like
like she was in his room they finished
[ __ ] he fell asleep she was going
through his phone and then i was just
like
oh and he was like yeah so i fell asleep
when she was going through my phones
like wait
wait i'm confused like were you guys
hooking up with something and then you
just like v
you know how unattractive you look when
you when you act this insecure like i
don't like that and he's like if we
don't have trust you used to always say
this to me if we don't have trust we
don't have anything and the fact that
you're acting like this right now is
making me feel like maybe we shouldn't
be together and then i always be like oh
my god i'm so sorry like you're right
like i'm so insecure and then you'd be
like okay can we just have sex and be
like yeah whatever you want wow
but see that also things that happened
to you in the past really affect the
relationships that you have today i
think i'm great i'm fine
okay there we go but you know what
honestly you learned a lot fair enough
but look where you are today i mean like
you wouldn't put up with that anymore
and i don't know that's like what that's
what happens when you do stick up for
yourself like there's things you still
learn that when you're in your 20s when
you're 30s like you're still growing and
you're learning yourself more and more
in relationships but i think the overall
like thing is don't let people walk on
you with friends and boyfriends don't
ever like half-ass or like
over-dramatize something that isn't even
like a thing yet like you don't never
know what people when you don't love
yourself
the way you feel about yourself is how
you allow others to treat you i didn't
understand how to love myself until
weirdly enough i started growing daddy
issues and when i started to grow daddy
issues is when i started to learn to
love myself and i remember towards the
end of our relationship i just i just
created daddy issues and remember he
said to me even though he was never
planning on marrying me he said to me
that's not very having an account like
that is not very wife material like how
do you expect me to anyone to ever wife
you up if you do that and i remember it
was that one moment i was like that's
crazy that then you're not the man for
me and i continue doing it because i
finally learned to love myself once i
learned to love myself
i just didn't put up with the [ __ ]
anymore he wasn't for me and guess what
happened
a year or two later
he texted me trying to start fight
because that would be our foreplay he uh
sorry if i it was like him to have sex
texted me like oh you're still crazy or
still this and that i was just like oh
hey how are you very calmly
he was trying to [ __ ] me
a month later and i rejected him a month
later he got engaged
and that told me
wow
he never changed i'm so lucky yeah i
didn't end up with this guy you did
you did honestly you
imagine
just imagine if you yeah everything
happens for a reason i feel like that is
the running theme of this podcast if
you're yourself you're going to attract
the best people for you in your life and
if you are you know
roll over like i did like you did in
that relationship like everyone yeah
even with friendships like
you're never gonna
be truly happy yourself and you're just
gonna live your life satisfying other
people
yeah i've learned so much yeah from just
talking to you now every time i hang out
with you i feel like i understand you a
little bit more me too because you are a
tough nut to crack you are but no i feel
like the more i've seen you the more
like i now i'm so understanding of like
how many similarities and differences we
do have but like learning that we get
from each other you know it's nice thank
you violet you have like literally just
given us so many golden nuggets and so
much information and i hope it works out
with this guy
i think you will i think we will where
can everyone find it right
right
right right yes
where can we find you um you guys can
find me uh my address is okay oh my god
social security
you can find me at daddy's shoes
underscore it's my meme account viola
events is my personal account to try to
be crazy is my podcast on every thursday
you guys can check out my episode right
now with these sisters it came out a few
days ago there's going to be a part two
coming out as well in the next week or
two so yeah don't forget to subscribe
and also shop daddy shoes.com yeah we
love you guys and we will see you next
tuesday bye
[Music]
you